this stadium in Frankfurt is normally
home to Bundesliga matches but this past
weekend there were cheers and chants of
a different kind 20,000 people came
together to watch the world's elite in
gaming at the biggest event for the
sport in Europe
here's a guy that has given design but I
don't really care who wins this is just
for fun I just want to watch the guys up
there there's a lot going on here this
is better than football who cares about
the euros we can see Dada here which is
so cool do me about this one daughter is
a fantasy game with half-human creatures
and magic swords for many fans it's a
chance to dress up as their virtual
heroes which they arranged beforehand
with other gamers we met the other three
guys online through games and said we
should go as a group of five he's the
only hero that exists five times this
game dota is one of the most popular
online games in the world it stands for
defense of the ancients ancients are
heavily guarded structures at opposing
corners of a map the aim of each team
made up of five players sitting in
strictly Shield of cabins is to destroy
the opposing sides ancient there's one
problem for spectators trying to get a
bird's-eye view of the keyboard it's not
exactly exciting to watch with
commentators and game analysts like
Allen Bester make the highly complex
event easier to follow the American is
actually an economics professor and says
there's many layers to the game that's
like saying describe chess in two
sentences there you can talk about how
the pieces move and you can talk about
your objective being to control the
opponent's side of the board but how you
accomplish that and the sheer number of
different ways there are to go about
doing that are what make the game truly
interesting but can this be considered a
sport for gamers there's no question
about it twenty-three-year-old Coroticus
owe me known as kuroki is the most
successful German eSports professional
he's won over 700 thousand euros in
prize money but he is a silent hero
preferring instead to focus on his mouse
and keyboard